so as you mentioned earlier you wrote
directed produced two shot and edited
Sherman's on looking back on it now is
there something that you wish you had
delegated to someone else
yeah I mean a lot a lot of different
ones actually I if DP is definitely up
there I you know I wish I had someone
else shoot it or leas camera operate
again I you know I feel I love the
collaboration I love having people give
their you know artistic sensibility on
top of what I'm trying to tell and
that's something that's very fun for me
working with a DP so that was something
I missed you know on this set it was
something i was actually looking forward
to but it you know it was out of
necessity ahead into it I think that's
probably the main one and a producer I
hate producing I I produce out of
necessity not because i love it but she
did such a beautiful job with the
cinematography so don't you think it was
a happy accident yeah you know I I I do
I actually because of its someone hired
me to DP their web series for a few
episodes I made some money and doing
that and you know I I wouldn't mind just
dping someone else's work or film you
know if they asked but the double duty
thing is a little tough I think you know
only a few people can really do it do it
well sort of work you know the exact
foresman with down and dangerous DP and
directed I don't know how he did it it's
beautiful looking film so I I would do
it again out of necessity if I had to
because I won't stop if it's if it comes
down to Gary you can make this film but
you have to shoot it yourself I'll do it
you know because I'm not going to stop
making films
you